[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hi
members of the yale graduating class of
2021 i'm robert lopez je class
of 1997. i'm a songwriter
best known along with my wife kristen
for co-writing the song
let it go and all the songs from frozen
frozen two
and most recently the theme songs for
one division
and i am so excited to get to be this
year's yale class day speaker
my time at yale was one of the
highlights of my life there hasn't been
a day that i haven't thought about some
great person i knew
great book i read a great memory i have
from yale
after i graduated i moved back home with
my parents without whose fierce support
i could never have
had a career in the arts i joined a
musical theater songwriting workshop
where i met jeff marks
with whom i wrote the show avenue q and
kristen anderson who became my wife
and my work wife my lyricist and my love
and somewhere along the way i co-wrote
the book of mormon with matt stone and
trey parker
over the span of my career i've been
able to share in many awards but always
in collaboration with some wonderful
person
so on class day i plan to talk about the
saving grace
of collaboration and friendship and how
it can take the weight of the world off
your stressed out shoulders
and i'll reflect a little on my time at
yale and share a memory and probably
even a song or two of course my speech
will only be part of the great tradition
of class day
i've spoken to the class day committee
and i'm so impressed with them and
everything they're planning it's going
to be great
so i want to say thanks to president
salove and everyone at yale for
entrusting me with this
it's a huge honor and i'm really looking
forward to seeing you on class day on
may 23rd thank you